I've talked to lots of business people
about leadership and there's a literature
on leadership,
but it's not a good literature.
It's,
it's pretty shallow.
Um,
partly because it's not that easy to
define leadership and partly because there
are different,
you know,
people have different temperaments and
different temperaments can be leaders.
They just do it in different ways.
Now there's something in
common about being a leader.
The,
and I would say one is that
if you're a natural leader,
you actually know where you're going,
right?
Cause what are you going to
do lead people in circles.
It's like maybe they'll follow
you but you're not a leader.
You're just a charlatan.
So you have to know where you're
going and then you have to be able to
communicate that and then
people have to trust you.
So you actually have to be honest,
cause people aren't that stupid.
At least not for a long period of time.
And then where are you going?
Has to have some value because otherwise,
why would anyone want
to go along with you?
So,
and then you might say,
well what,
what are the attributes
then that make you a leader?
And I would say well
they're characterological
fundamentally and this is not
naive optimism or,
or or casual demoralizing.
It has nothing to do with that.
You know,
we know for example that conscientious
that the personality trait is a good
predictor of long term success
in in most occupations,
not all but most.
And that one of the things that's
associated with conscientiousness is that
people keep their word,
they're trustworthy.
And that's certainly
one element of a leader,
especially across any
reasonable amount of time.
You have to be able to trust the person.
They can even be harsh,
right?
It doesn't matter because you can
see harsh leaders and kind leaders,
but as long as they do what they say
they will do and then you can follow them
and you know that the future payoff is,
is,
is secure,
something like that.
So the idea that character,
logical development is more important
to leadership then primogenitor I think
that's the right word.
Ah,
premo genesis anyways,
being a first born,
that's a very crucial psychological
realization that its character,
logical development that
makes you favored of God.
You know?
And I do think we've forgotten this in
many ways because there isn't a lot of
emphasis in our education system
on characterological development.
And that's very,
very surprising to me.
I think maybe it's partly
because in our fractured society,
we can't agree on what constitutes
a reasonable character,
a logical goal.
So we just throw up our hands and don't
educate our kids to any degree at all,
especially in schools about what
an admirable person is like,
or even let them know that,
well,
maybe you should actually try to be one.
You know that that's actually the most
important possible thing that you could
learn.